age sucks and you gotta face it yeah
but is it because america is really so
youth obsessed i mean how
and in the film you show you know kind
of that it is hard for a woman of your
age to get
the job it's beyond difficult the only
jobs
really left now for women unless they
get friendly with people to do
films but
the only jobs that are really
commercials i just thank god
my i made my yearly nut this year on a
product called girly which is for dry
vagina
and it's
well anyone knows the heartbreak of dry
[Applause]
vaginas
i was perfect for it cattle's follow me
[Applause]
home
three jewish men are trying to rent my
uterus instead of going to miami
and this thank god for these commercials
there's one called an uh zestra
is that come here yet
it's like woman's uh viagra has that
happened here yet it's women's
viagra and they have this big discussion
with me
should they make it in pill form this is
honest to god truth it was in the
newspapers
pill form or cream because they didn't
know which
would do better and they finally decide
these idiots will do it in cream because
if it's in pill form
in a bar a man can drop it in a woman's
drink
and she won't know it but if you're in a
bar and a guy goes so where you from
[Applause]
i was back there freaking out you're
like the first person who said it
perfectly really yeah i'll stop now i
won't
say it again amazing 15 years and then
you came along
it all changes here by the way you guys
do you know each other outside
of being back there or on a sofa i know
john
and i don't know steve no no cause i've
seen him on the telly
you know that's not real i know i know
now it is jubilee weekend uh do you have
plans
anybody got plans i uh i didn't realize
it was jubilee weekend but when i got
here i got in
town a couple days ago and was invited
uh
i guess to sit next to the queen um
on the boat going down there that's
amazing
i'm not gonna do it
i don't i don't know her
four hours and what are we gonna talk
about i don't own
crowns or tiaras or no i don't know if
you're joking or not are you joking
oh no i'm completely joking
he has been invited on the boat i'm
really confused now
well no
did you lie to him as well to me as well
yes john
it's a great story it really is i didn't
even know there was going to be a boat
and at least you were thinking
do they know i have an oscar
do they not know just another thing you
don't have in common with the queen
now charlize theron now we're
delighted you're here for all sorts of
reasons i'm so happy to be i'm a huge
fan
thank you
episode one the doctor's thing yeah did
that really happen
yeah my mum will kill me for telling
this because it was my uh
our family doctors and i i he'd been our
family
my doctor since i was a child but i went
as an adult
because i i was there's something wrong
with my
bum you said bum you looked at me
directly in the eyes i'm sorry i'm
aroused and unnerved
there was something but there was
something wrong with my
bum
[Laughter]
there's this thing wrong with my bum and
he went okay and i went
so what'd you think he goes well
it'll probably be all right and i said
well
i would really like it i'd like you to
just
if you could make me feel better about
if i feel better that it will be all
right
and he went it'll probably clear itself
up and i said
yeah but is there any way i could be
sure and he went ah
you want me to put my finger up there
don't you
maybe there's a reason but what is the
reason that you film it
in the school you used to teach in i
think it's therapy probably
i'm in the actual classroom where i talk
because i was just to keep the theme
going a real teacher for a long time
yeah i taught for
yeah six years in the school that we
film it in the classroom that i'm going
mad in and i
that's that's really well that was my
classroom yeah but you did it
did you ever enjoy it was there ever a
moment when you thought oh i like this
i don't know okay
well i met some very nice people there
and the kids must like you you were
nominated for teacher of the year
weren't you yes i was great
i was yeah you know yes i've told this
story many times
teacher of the year is a very
prestigious award that's taken very
seriously and rightly by the
hard-working teaching community
and my head teacher called me in and he
was wetting himself laughing
he couldn't stop laughing for the first
10 minutes and he went
i went what why have you called me here
he goes you've been um
a teacher of the year awards have been
nominated
and i went oh okay and it was by a very
sweet girl called gemma i've humiliated
many times
and it's a six-page document that people
have to fill in
for the reasons why you should be
nominated for teacher of the year
it was blank aside from one sentence
that she'd written on it
which was of the reasons why you think
he should be teacher of the year and
she'd written
he's a well good laugh and he don't make
us do no work
why haven't we seen more of you two
together
it's a pairing it really is it's a match
made in heaven
oh yeah now um jackie chan yes jackie
chan
uh yes what
i haven't done that once i'm very
similar i'm sitting on my hands i'm
going jackie chan i'm
not doing this because is it true that
everyone just goes jackie chan yeah
i really hate that you know
whenever i go you know in europe in
america especially the father with
children
look yeah
why why nobody say robert de niro
that's robert de niro wow dustin hoffman
[Laughter]
one day one day i hope people wow that's
a jackie chan
yes yes there's jackie chan
i'm trying i'm trying to restrain myself
you just come from the the cannes film
festival yeah can film
do you enjoy things like that are they
fun or is it
just like business the the the whole
thing about the
those big uh events they call them you
know particularly in candles red carpet
things
and do you enjoy them do you like doing
that no i can't do any of that i really
can't
i've seen you i did go well have you on
a red carpet i don't think so
no have you i've seen you show up at
things not much to be honest
but you've you've done posh things
you've you've mixed with roy you've
met the queen haven't you i have met the
queen yes i have no queen
adam i think it was a uh one of those
receptions for people in the arts
you should have been there graham honey
i watched you were overlooked yes i was
yeah
yeah i was you know what i was amazed at
with the queen she's very
tiny which is something for me today
because i'm quite short
and she moves as if on rollerblades
she just slides up like that is there's
no actual walking skull i don't know
what's going on under there
she might be on casters but
as she comes to where you are the group
where you are
uh for a start you have to you have to
tussle with that whole idea of will you
curtsy weren't you cursing will you
curtsy
and i decided before no look curtsy it's
no i'm not going to bow down before
roy i'm not going to and then
immediately you do
immediately you cursing far too much
and then and then the queen says there
was a group about four of us around her
and she says a very small thing you know
so are you enjoying the evening and
everybody goes like this
i think people are just nervous are they
eager to please don't want to be
beheaded or something
so the queen i'm sure must think that
she's a great comedian or something
that's all she sees is people fawning
and laughing at everything she says
i was doing it
i remember and a long long time ago
my english is so bad in that time uh
remember when queen
raise your hand you use your hand
otherwise you're standing here blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah
and you're right what your royal
highness yes yes
yeah i didn't have to remember your
royal highness you were right highness
dennis
what we playing around queen's coming
quiz come in there everybody
what should i say then i see the queen
stop
stop stop so quick oh okay
then when she comes you're right
she keep talking to me
my head is empty i don't know what she's
talking about
[Laughter]
you know honestly again go go away
leave me alone of course i'm so happy
just standing here
more than like a three minute five
minutes but i just don't go away please
don't talk to me anymore
that's right if they're in new zealand
that's right yes
and they've been stopped they got
whisked off on a little um oh that's
trolling that's a hell of a
all i service was a glass of champagne
can we say whisked on bbc one i think
you can't say whisked off
[Applause]
did you drive yourself here tonight no
no no no i've got my driving list
license no and still aren't driving me
would you get in the car with him
in a black mariah no it depends
but now my husband is officially allowed
to drive yes i would get in a car with
him
he took 61 years but i mean in terms of
teaching you
didn't know well before i was too pissed
to draw yeah
okay fair enough i mean i would go for
my test and i'll go
let's see me and i go no mr osborne come
back another day i'm not even getting in
the car
with you walking around the test center
with a bottle of eye cream i probably
didn't go anything
did you learn in a manual or an
automatic i can drive anything one of
those
few tricks
is there anything you can use yet no
i'll go
is there anything that can go on bbc one
not yet you've just had a promotion it's
all dvd extras i know
but it's a proper western i mean we see
tom hanks gun toten which we rarely see
well i don't have i don't wear one i am
given one
later on so it's not like you know i'm
not doing the root and tubing kind of
but i i i i ride a horse
and um i drive a wagon and i've
discovered so i'm not a
i'm not a writer per se but i did learn
i i had a fabulous
got to know a fabulous horp named wimpy
who was my horse
wimpy was my fault and um i don't know
if anybody here is
has ridden a lot or made a western emily
has a couple of westerns under her belt
as i recall emily my darling how are
you how are you wonderful to see it's
good to see you
do you know i'm about to do a western
like next january i'm doing a six-part
western and we were just discussing how
allergic i am to horses and i do every
scene with a horse
you know i'm going to be antihistamined
up to my eyeball
do you have to kiss the horse
isn't that what happens in western to
make out with your horse
you you develop an affection for those
beasts
every morning you throw your arms around
with you how are you my darling little
chestnut i'm so
nuts which you sort of have to do
because i have a feeling that horses
honestly they would much rather live in
a world without human beings climbing on
top of them
and they know the moment you climb on
their back that you're terrible at
riding like i mean i've been learning
right
now i'm i'm in london now rehearsing for
it and i go riding
three times a week and every time they
give me a different horse to see
you know how you fell oh with one that's
more sporty or one that's less of a
ferrari and i got on one the other day
called rusty
oh my god they almost took off with me
it was terrifying
i couldn't walk the next day rusty did
me in
[Laughter]
rusty did her in rusty did man
oh wow is that the name of the film
oh my god look at you now sir patrick
stewart and you don't really use this
sir much do you um
or should i sorry should i have been
calling you no i shouldn't am i supposed
to
no okay but but no do you i take my lead
from
whom we've both shared some time with
yes and uh
he is he is so phlegmatic about all of
that
and and i just you know it's a great
honor but
it's not something that i need to press
when you
bump into another sir when you're out
and about do you then
do you you call each other well yeah so
you must roll in circles
circles
[Applause]
so how do you become a sir um
patrick well you know
it's a case of um
i got mine on the queen's birthday
honors but you have reminded me
that i did have a sir encounter
only a few weeks ago in los angeles a
rather
fancy in fact extremely fancy restaurant
tell them what it is they'll know um it
was the uh
the the tower bar
no yeah no yeah guys that's cool
no no no no no no no no se say it again
look at this
oh man
[Applause]
keep going you keep going keep going
okay no the towel bar is the spot
i got a feeling this isn't gonna work
out
um so we had four of us were seated at a
table
about 15 minutes later into the
restaurant walks
sir paul mccartney wow good now
paul and i have a very slender
relationship but it's lasted decades
okay i first encountered him in 1964.
no when his girlfriend
jane asher then told him that i
loved aston martin's i was driving a
battered old ford but aston martins were
my dream car
she told him this and one night yeah we
knew he was seeing the show there was a
knock on my door
and i said yeah come in i'm there in my
underwear like
as usual
and the door opened and standing there
was paul mccartney who i had never met
before
and this was 1964 and uh
he said jane says that you like aston
martin's here
drive this wow and he tossed a bunch of
keys off pretty cool
and it was an ass it was
amazing anyway do you want to hear the
rest let's keep going keep going
we're in we're in the fanciest
restaurant in l.a we're now in the tower
i am feeling less and less good
keep going keep going you're in there so
paul mccartney has come in
you've known him he's in the 60s and uh
he sees me and comes over and uh i stand
up and say hi and we have a big hug
in the restaurant and i'm very much
aware that there's
all the tables are full and this kind of
thing and we talk for five or six
minutes
and he goes and sits down five minutes
go by and
into the restaurant walks so ringo starr
i swear to you i'm not saying i'm not
making this were they together
they were they were oh they were at the
same table they were the same yes
um well uh we we are
at the tower
i am expecting so many free meals
and um we finish early
and i get up to go and paul stands up to
say goodbye and we have a hug
and as we have a hug he says into my ear
do you know ringo i said yeah of course
i've never met him but he said oh boy
ringo come on come over here
hang on a minute he said sir ringo
sir patrick sir paul hey we've got the
knights of the roundtable
[Applause]
[Music]
you